mes enfants seraient rentrés les
passeports arrivé au bout pas malgré sa
contre mon contre mon vouloir on a
renouvelé les passeports de mes enfants
savoir aussi que dans mon divorce rémy
d'ailleurs à réclamer de l'argent
du jamais vu pour le juge quand même
hein il a réclamé 30 35 mille euros dans
mon divorce
ils ont produit des faux des fausses
fiches de paye une fiche de paye ou au
30 avril 30 février
moi par exemple oui il y en a eu des
fautes ils sont malins ouais ouais ils
sont vraiment en plus c'est là la hausse
et les iris browser de la tenir ouais
ouais voilà le fasse et des génies mais
ils sont quand même rémunérés quand même
très dangereux parce que ils brassent
quoi il ya le pouvoir il a vu l'état de
ses comptes en banque il ya qu'il ya des
inconnues quoi nous on les connaît pas
on ne sait pas notre top là moi ce soir
je suis quand même la peau syrie pour
faire un appel au secours
avant toute chose et ça ça fait depuis
cinq ans n'e peu dingo enfants voilà et
puis surtout là les enfants dorment par
terre dans une prison sans matelas je
dire on aider on est des européens et on
est des français on est des européens
on traite pas nos concitoyens comme ça
j'ai passé comme ça oui c'est des
enfants on a là un et un état c'est tout
ce qui peut je le pense
aujourd'hui l'état fait ce qu'il peut
mais le problème c'est la malaisie
aujourd'hui en plus ils sont rentrés
aujourd'hui dans un couvre-feu spéciale
donc c'est très compliqué pour les
services du ministère des affaires
étrangères à votre combat aujourd'hui
c'est le retour de sanayeh et dylan dan
enfin l'as et d'avoir le regard des deux
revoilà évidemment c voilà qui soir
scolarisés qu est ce qu on vous lit vous
avez fait quelles démarches bas j'ai
fait toutes les démarches possibles et
inimaginables j'ai fait déjà appelé des
associations jamais sans papa qu'est ce
qu'on vous dit ben on nous dit que c'est
la malaisie et que et que voilà et puis
donc il semble que quand même rémy
daillet et comme pas mal de l'influent
d'influencé de relations quoi puisque
mon divorce a été épique ainsi rice a
été le premier juge juge me dis ouais
les enfants rendent tout de suite c'est
quoi cette histoire en gros un mois
après le juge change comme par magie il
change tout alors que bon bah y'a pas et
on n'est pas au pénal il ya des y'a pas
une nouveau faire donc on monte on le
démonte des boutons ne dit pas non vos
enfants rentrent pas voilà et au final
ben moi avec un paquet de preuves comme
ça un défaut tout ça mon finale entre
guillemets on gagne jamais
ce que les enfants sont parvenus je n'ai
pas gagné mais bon aujourd'hui la
décision de justice qui dit que vos
enfants doivent rentrer ou pas alors
j'ai une décision de justice qui me
donne la garde de mes enfants c'est ça
tous les étés un qui n'a jamais leur
hymer ag a été appliquée bas remy
daillet a pas envie que mes enfants je
leur raconte la vérité avec écueil l on
leur explique surtout à sa taille parce
que le petit est neuf ans donc on ne
l'épargnera mai mais voilà donc il n'a
pas envie qu'on fasse tomber le masque
ans alors on est gay le maître maître
jean christophe bassons lardy merci vous
êtes avocat de rémy d'ail et quand vous
entendez toute cette histoire vous
répondez quoi parce que c'est la
première on a tous quand je pense que
tous les téléspectateurs qui regardent
l'émission soir ses 10 ans on aimerait
que ses enfants retournent chez leur
père et chez leur grand frère alors une
série de moi quand j'entends cette
histoire si je considère un tant soit
peu les choses d'une façon un petit peu
objective extérieur jeu j'entends et je
prends la responsabilité de le dire
j'entends un tissu de mensonges
j'entends des choses qui sont à dormir
debout donc ce n'est pas parce que ce
monsieur énoncé un certain nombre de
choses il faut prendre pour argent
comptant ce qu'il dit mais il y avait de
la première des choses c'est important
qui va croire sur un plateau télé qu'un
enfant de 14 ans peut s'enfuir et
prendre un avion tout seul un enfant de
14 ans il est remis au personnel
navigant par quelqu'un qui a l'autorité
parentale à savoir par sa mère ça c'est
la première des choses là deux ce n'est
pas un c'est la première des choses sur
la plus grosse énormité qui a été dit je
suis pas là pour ça encore une fois je
suis là pour lancer un véritable appel à
l'aide et pas pour essayer d'
instrumentaliser une situation de surfer
sur une vague pour faire valoir des
droits qui ont déjà étaient et bien et
qui ont déjà été demandés auprès de la
justice monsieur il a prétendu qu'ils
avaient un élément international de ses
enfants
interpol a été saisie les autorités
françaises ont agi en collaboration en
coopération avec les autorités
malaisiennes
ça a été classée sans suite monsieur des
poses très régulièrement des plaintes
pénales pour non représentation d'enfant
puisque il prétend que l'on ne peut pas
quand qu'on ne lui donne pas comme il le
disait hier l'instant et bien des
victimes cgt d'hébergement donc ses
enfants non mais je ne voudrais pas
coupé comme pas mais moi je vous coupe
possibilité effectivement c'est pas
possible je vous dis d'avoir ses enfants
pendant une période qui est prévu le
jugement me plaindre parce que j'ai un
divorce une charge les billets monsieur
et je viens au quai de l'adour et de
n'importe quoi messieurs il a des droits
qui le fait voler son planning de la
télévision